hey guys and welcome to a kind of
sporadic and extremely random video but
I just couldn't resist look at this this
is an item that is dropped by a snail
this is the bamh blue snail or shell one
it's selling for
19k 19 and even 5K [__] it whatever uh
if we go look at the other
blemish um blue shell see if there's a
bunch of different types there should
only be two so that the curved top what
the [__] is that all right here's the
other one uh not worth nearly as much
but why is it even worth 1.3k at all
anyway we're at the snails and we are
getting these things really quickly um I
have no clue why people are paying this
much for these things uh but I don't
know I I'm just going to try doing this
for a little while and see how much
money I make we don't really want these
guys yeah not those ones okay so this is
what I'm doing I'm just hopping worlds
and there's seems to be one spawn pretty
much consistently in the kind of
Northeast section of the fairy ring so
we just kind of killed the snail [__]
off the gas are really annoying and uh
see you and that is going to be uh easy
18K so this is my inventory so far now
we'll have to see if I actually sell it
for 18K cuz that would be ridiculous
252k in profit already even 70 I mean
I've only been here for like 5 minutes
maybe most um so yeah this is in really
strange I never thought a snail would be
any good but yeah so we'll go ahead and
do maybe a couple inventories of this
and then we'll see if we can actually
sell it off okay so we have a pretty
much full inventory uh this only took me
about 10 minutes I could get about a
shell or two every 30 seconds uh because
I was just basically killing one hopping
world uh really easy it's another 18K I
think anyway uh so we'll go back to the
Grand exchange and we're going to go
price check one of these cuz I was
literally in the middle of recording ing
another video and all of a sudden I I'm
just looking in the grand exchange for
items to flip and this shell pops up I'm
like the [__] is the shell and then I um
go look into it a little bit more and
apparently it's 100% drop rate from a
[__] snail so I'm going to go ahead
and see if we can sell these all right
so we're going to start off by
checking the price uh in the grand
exchange first uh so can we buy one for
20K 19k hey holy [__] all right what can
we sell this for I'm interested to see
what we can insta sell these for
theoretically 5K like even 5K that's not
bad for 10 minutes of work that would be
would be as good that still be 700k an
hour though but um we're going to go
ahead and sell it
for
18500 and that was literally 10 minutes
500k I'm not sure if these are actually
going to come through or not but let's
go do another inventory [__] it um we'll
double down and we'll be back in a
minute all right this should be our last
snail of this inventory I went a little
quicker now cuz I actually know what I'm
doing I'm true snail Hunter I guess now
and uh I feel like these things I I miss
them more frequently than I should for a
level 20 snail but whatever there we go
we got another full inventory of these
blemish blue snail shells and we'll just
head back to the gr change uh so if we
have a look at the item in G
tracker doesn't trade a lot um wait this
isn't the right one all right so yeah it
doesn't trade a lot but let's see how
many per day uh 30 or 40 so I I don't
know maybe we could actually sell these
off all right well we'll pop these in
here for 18400 as well and yeah so
that's 1 mil in profit and only took us
about 20 to 25 minutes uh so we're going
to head out for the day and uh well
we'll see if these actually sell all
right so we're back for the day uh we
haven't checked on this in a little
while so let's see if we manag to sell
any of these shells in 20 4 to 27 Oh my
God how many do we sell we go to the
Grand
exchange and we sold pretty much all of
the ones for, 18400 that is insane uh
guess we'll drop these down as well I
mean who [__] I don't care with the
extra bit of money I'm not sure if this
made a difference at all but all right
so that was pretty much uh well let's
see been about 12 or 13 hours uh so I
actually sold more than I thought I
would and uh the price still seems to be
high around
18400 um so I think we'll just leave
these in overnight and come back and
check in another little bit okay so for
the final check I kind of cheated here
so but anyway um we did sell everything
all 54 blemish blue snail shells look at
that doesn't that look super
nice all right so 54 of them sold for
$1,400 each each of these is given us
pretty well 500k in profit and honestly
only took about 10 minutes for each of
those runs so about 20 minutes in total
and we got about a mill which is crazy
now once again this is not a
money-making guide this is
just something kind of just I found it's
not really meant to be a repeatable
thing but it's an opportunity and um
well it worked out pretty well for me
and it was kind of funny cuz they're
just they're just snails who would have
thought that something from a snail so
insignificant could have been worth so
much all hope you guys enjoyed this fun
little video and I'll see you guys in
the next
one